para richard royal ex bombero de nueva
york sigue siendo doloroso venir aquí
los nombres de los amigos que perdió
están grabados en el mármol del
monumento a la 'zona cero' reichardt
pasó varios días buscando entre los
escombros a los supervivientes de los
atentados del 11 de septiembre
sobre estaba rogando por traer a alguien
a casa y me rompe el maldito corazón que
no haya traído a nadie a casa sino un
pedazo de ropa con algo en ella con
alguien eso no es alguien los héroes ese
día fueron los que estaban en los
edificios y los que entraron y murieron
richie arriesgó su vida para ayudar a
otros poniendo en peligro su propia
salud
uno de hombres está ahora dañado
richie también sufre un trastorno de
estrés postraumático nutella una perra
de apoyo psicológico lo acompaña por
todas partes por su parte anne marie
percibe superviviente del 11 de
septiembre sufre su segundo cáncer
relacionado con los atentados ella
también padece trastorno de estrés
postraumático
había gente en el techo esperando que
vinieron helicóptero por ellos pero el
humo y el calor eran tan intensos que
los helicópteros no podían aterrizar y
luego hubo lo que pensamos que eran
muebles lanzados por las ventanas antes
de darnos cuenta de que eran personas y
cuando las torres se derrumbaron todos
empezamos a correr estaba oscuro era
humo polvo y ceniza no podía respirar y
luego durante días tosía ceniza que
salía por la piel sudaba ceniza y polvo
psicológicamente es porque como dice
rich y como puedes darle sentido
richie y and my forman parte de la
fundación feel good que defiende los
derechos del personal de rescate y otras
víctimas de atentados terroristas para
que reciban el tratamiento médico que
necesitan